[Musique]
bonjour depuis le 16 juin les députés de
la commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 auditionnent
les acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi ancien ministre et
directeur généraux de la santé tout
l'été lcp vous fait revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui suite et fin de
celle de didier rahout avec le franc
parler qu'on lui connaît le célèbre
infectiologues est revenu sur la très
controversée hydroxy chloroquine il a
également réitéré ses accusations de
conflit d'intérêts générés par les
grands laboratoires à travers tout
d'autres interventions vous êtes en
train de nous dès que vous voyez de le
décrire un monde de conflit d'intérêts
ou d'intérêt absolument puissant y
compris lorsque vous avez quitté le
conseil scientifique vous avez abordé le
conseil scientifique de vidic d'être pas
assez de temps pour passer à participer
à des couillonnades et dans le même
temps vous nous expliquer que finalement
ces gens là travaillent entre eux et
qu'on avait qu'à regarder où étaient les
conflits d'intérêts ce que dit le
journal marianne d'ailleurs par ailleurs
dans un article récent moi j'aurais aimé
que nous en dit plus là dessus parce que
vous pouvez pas nous mettre sur une
piste
l'objectif comme l'a dit la présidente
c'est quand même de trouver comment ça
ne se reproduit pas vous allez donner
des pistes sur les centres de référence
etc
mais comment dirais-je il faut quand
même qu'on sache un peu où sont les
lièvres à soulever pour éviter que ça
puisse se reproduire
et d'ailleurs si vous nous avez décrit
un certain nombre de choses vous avez
peut-être omis de parler de la place du
secrétariat général à la défense
nationale pendant la crise et pas dans
la préparation de la crise et dernier
point j'ai été frappé dans l'article du
parisien je crois encore que vous ayez
dit qu'il vous paraissait improbable que
nous puissions obtenir un vaccin
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi ce virus-là
pourrait enfin il ya des virus compas
d'axa mais pourquoi celui-ci qui paraît
plus simple quand on lit des choses
qu'on n'est pas médecin ni candidat ni
rien pourquoi ça vous semble improbable
de trouver un vaccin alors ces deux
questions je je pense comme toi je vous
le dis je pense que c'est pas ça fera
partie de votre enquête parlementaire
moi je vous recommande de faire une
véritable enquête sur gilead air india
si vous regardez la structure de gilead
vous comprendrez que c'est quelque chose
qui ne fonctionne qu'avec très très peu
de produits très peu de personnel et une
influence considère donc l'essentiel de
sa stratégie basée sur l'influent
moi j'ai été je vous le rappelle moi
quand j'ai commencé à parler pour la
première fois la chloroquine ya
quelqu'un qui m'a menacé à plusieurs
reprises manière anonyme
j'ai porté plainte et j'ai fini par
trouver que c'était celui qui avait reçu
le plus d'argent de wilaya depuis six
ans d'accord donc si vous voulez j'ai d
une expérience personnelle d'accord de
fonctionnement qui ne me paraissent pas
normaux peut-être que c'est une
coïncidence mais c'est pas sûr parce
qu'il me disait qu'il interdisait de
parler de claude d'accord j'ai les mails
j'ai porté plainte officiellement la
police on sait qui c'est d'accord donc
le niveau de problème là est un niveau
de problème sur lequel moi je vous
suggère d'être attentif
c'est pas compliqué de regarder encore
une fois qu'il ya des conflits intérêts
vaut garder le listing vous regardez le
listing chez les infectiologues vous
regarde et on a même publié un article
là dessus pour dire écoutez les deux
tiers et on a même fait un article
malicieux en en regardant les gens qui
s'est exprimé dans la presse pour ou
contre la chloroquine et on a match et
ça avec le nombre d'argent qu'ils
avaient reçu de de guilers et c'est
parfaitement match et je ne dis pas la
causalité et la corrélation sont deux
choses différentes
donc je dis pas qu'il ya une causalité
mais une coïncidence au sens
étymologique donc cesser la même
incidence d'être contre la chloroquine
et et de recevoir l'argent de guilad
donc je vous suggère très fortement de
poser la question de savoir le niveau
moi je n'avais jamais vu d'un flux ans
d'une seule compagnie sur le
fonctionnement qui mon sens inclus dans
le monde des choses qui sont bien au
delà de celle du médiator donc ça
existait déjà
ça avait quand même donc ça existait
déjà là pour cet enjeu là ça a pris une
ampleur qui voit là et des rapports
s'étaient développées entre ce groupe
acting et gilead pour la tentative
d'utiliser un décideur qui a été un
échec pour ebola ça n'a pas marché mais
ce groupe s'était formé au déjà autour
de ça et donc il ya des liens multiples
et pour pour vous pour aller jusqu'au
bout des choses moi j'ai été surpris de
voir que le directeur de gilead devant
le président a répliqué devant le
ministre tutoyer celui qui était en
charge des essais thérapeutiques en
france pour kobe de 19
moi j'ai pas l'habitude de me faire
tutoyer par là directeur l'industrie
pharmaceutique s'il faisait un jeu en
répondant vous voyant je le ferai pas
donc je pense qu'il ya des jeux pour
vous dire vite et je sais même pas si ça
n'est que des liens d'intérêts je vous
dis pas que les gens ont été achetés
pour ça mais les gens de créer un
écosystème encore une fois qui est un
écosystème favorable dans lequel la
vision qu'on a du monde est différente
et donc je pense que c'est ces relations
de familiarité ou de départ ensemble de
voyage ensemble amène à une vision et un
écosystème qui est d'une nature à
permettre à changer le jugement des
choses je crois ça et je n'ai pas
d'exemple contraire j'ai vu ça mon
époque moi quand j'étais jeune et ça
c'était les antibiotiques donc je me
rappelle je décide de faire ça du tout
possible et une croisière qui a été
organisée par un médicament qui a
disparu maintenant s'appelle la place in
où il y avait 700 médecins qui avaient
été invités vous savez que les premières
règles de sur la déclaration obligatoire
des liens d'intérêts a été faite après
que merck et inviter tous les médecins
de france aller en chine pour des
congrès factice d'accord et c'est la
conquête est mis en place l'obligation
de déclaration de l'ia ou de financement
auprès du conseil le professeur sur le
vaccin s'est passé
je ne pouvais pas aller autrement aussi
sur le vaccin
si vous voulez moi j'entends j'entends
bien que qu'à chaque fois qu'il ya un
nouveau virus y à novak ça qui va
arriver etc mais si vous regardez là
aussi je vous suggère de regarder c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est bien qu' une
erreur que je vais vous rectifié vaut
garder d'en avaler ball vaccine de
belles choses que veut dire quels sont
les vaccins disponibles sur le site de
l'om est ce vous regardez et vous vous
regarder s'il ya et puis après tout et
max en développement ça c'est les
possibles dans le vrai est dans le vrai
il ya deux faux d'ailleurs ils disent
qu'il ya vaccin pour le paludisme ce qui
n'est pas vrai vous pouvez pas acheter
un accent sur le palier et ils disent
qu'il ya vaccin sur l'hépatite e ce qui
est pas vrai il y en a qu'un qui ai
commencé à être développé en chine donc
et vous regardez si là dedans il ya
beaucoup de vaccins qui ont moins de 30
ans et vous verrez et puis vous vous
poserez la question tout cas moi je me
pose c'est pourquoi en france on fait
pas la vaccination contre la varicelle
il ya plusieurs centaines milliers de
cas ont fait pas le vaccin contre le
rotavirus ont fait pas le vaccin contre
la grippe chez les enfants qui tue des
enfants d'accord et donc ça veut dire
que l'implantation des vaccins ensuite
al-aqsa ça devient ensuite un problème
politique sociale et donc le degré la
capacité de que nous avons eu 30
dernières années à faire des vaccins qui
sont implantés et complexe et elle va
être encore plus complexe avec les
courants la vie est de mon point de vue
bien que j'en connaisse pas l'issue
parce que nous avons depuis une
expérience de la dengue ou la dengue est
un des seuls nouveaux vaccins il s'est
trouvé que la dengue chez les gens qui
n'avaient pas eu de dengue est exposé à
faire des dingues plus sévère que celle
des gens qui n'avaient pas été vaccinés
et on savait ça que le deuxième épisode
de dengue est très sévère taylorisés moi
j ai donc si vous n'avez pas d'une
protection vous faites une dingue banale
si vous avez déjà fait une dingue ou si
elle fait un vaccin
eh bien vous faites une dengue sévère et
c'était une très mauvaise surprise est
une des raisons pour lesquelles des
philippines en particulier on
attaquent les gens qui est vaccinée donc
c'est pas si simple que ça va merci
monsieur penchèrent oui ce professeur à
la controverse sur la chloroquine n'en
serait peut-être pas arriver là si comme
vous le soulignez on n'était pas un des
rares pays en france où c'est le
ministre de la santé qui dit comment
soigner en utilisant tel ou tel
médicament alors que partout ailleurs
sont les médecins qui sont libres de
prescrire en fonction de ce qu'ils ont
appris
votre intervention il ya quelques
instants c'est un ode à la révolution
girondine
c'est à dire 7 mettre fin cette
centralisation dans beaucoup de domaines
et notamment dans le domaine et
notamment dans le domaine de la santé
alors moi je veux revenir sur la
question des tests on est en avril
on teste pas où on teste peu sauf
évidemment chez vous ça commence les
français découvrent médusés que il ya
des tests dans les pays qui nous
entourent
on est mieux on est en avril il ya des
tas de laboratoire qui se tournent les
pouces et qui demandent qu'à tester et
comment est on teste pas et on teste pas
la france n'a commencé à mener des
campagnes de détection massive que mi
avril alors que l'italie et l'allemagne
disposent et de tests en nombre
suffisant début début avril nous on
teste à partir de mi-mai il aurait fallu
sept cent mille tests dans notre pays
dès début avril pendant le pic de
l'équipe l'épidémie mais sa part été le
cas vous êtes un des rares exemples de
laboratoire ou prenez en main à travers
150 mille tests effectués et ce qu'il en
a pas été avec les tests comme avec les
masques
nous n'avions pas suffisamment mais
comme nous n'étions pas organisés pour
en acquérir et en distribuant distribués
on a expliqué en plus dès le début de la
crise que ça servait à rien tester tous
nos dispositifs de gestion test est
concentré et vous l'avez indiqué c'est
qu'à partir de début avril qu'on se rend
enfin compte qu'il faut tester
massivement les pouvoirs publics
incitent à leur vécu et partout des
tests poussés sait où c'est possible
alors je voulais revenir sur le
professeur froguel qui est au chu de
lille et qui vit dans l'histoire des
tests tout le monde ment les directeurs
d'hôpitaux emmanuel macron en passant
par la direction générale de la santé et
olivier ferrand
partagez vous ce sentiment sur l'absence
de transparence et la cacophonie et est
ce que vous pouvez répondre très
précisément à cette simple question
combien de temps avons nous perdu à peu
près et qu'on vienne morts on aurait pu
éviter
encore une fois mon jeu à part sur cette
chose qui est assez simple puisqu'il ya
rapporte 4500 personnes qui ont été
hospitalisées à paris et qu'on voit
qu'il ya 20% de moins en dehors avec
roxy clarkin on peut calculer manière
relativement simple peut-être fausse
parce que trop simple qu'on met à mort
pour l'asse c'est complexe
je suis d'accord froger par exemple
avait écrit que lui il pouvait faire le
millier de pcr par jour et que sa
direction le interdit de le faire donc
il y avait le fait de il ya eu un
mécanisme qui s'est fait dont je sais
pas comment il s'est fait mais il ya eu
un mécanisme qui s'est fait ces
puisqu'on peut pas faire les tests les
tests sont inutiles et c'était l'idée
qu'on pouvait pas faire les tests
n'étaient pas vains et donc cette idée
de on peut pas faire les tests est une
idée qui a foi une idée de monopole une
idée de ça va être compliqué une idée de
ou vont être les réactifs
je sais que par exemple pour les
extractions on utilise parmi les
machines qu'on utilise y en a une qui
est des plus utilisés qui est une
machine il s'appelle qiagen qui fabrique
des réactifs en allemagne et aux etats
unis
et je sais qu'aux états unis ils auront
tout de suite interdit l'exportation de
tous les réactifs qui agit toujours
lendemain parce qu'ils ont à dire en
situation de crise on les veut tous
partent opus relativement tôt donc ça
veut dire qu'il ya des positions si vous
voulez c'est pour ça encore une fois ça
revient cette question moi c'est aussi
une des choses dont j'avais discuté avec
le président j'ai dit je pense que d'une
crise cette nature doit être gérée par
le secrétaire national de la défense
nationale parce que j'avais vu que quand
moi je vais thomis sert de santé que
celui qui était plus raisonnable c'est
lui - parmi tous les directeurs parce
que
quand j'étais en plus et directeur de
discuter entre eux et donc y avait
quatre versions successives qui arrivait
au sgdn si vous voulez parce que
directeur était pas d'accord donc simple
et complexe la france donc il faut un
moment le donneur d'ordre c'est le
responsable de la sécurité publique
c'est mon avis cela étant je suis
d'accord avec vous que la sécurité
publique ne devrait pas jusqu'à
interdire aux médecins et aux
pharmaciens de distribuer des
médicaments qui ont fait la preuve de
leur innocuité depuis 80 ans et je vais
vous donner une anecdote parce que
j'adore l'histoire
peut-être que vous savez passe à
l'histoire de la chloroquine ça remonte
très loin ça vient du pérou où ça vient
du quinquennat et il ya eu un drame
similaire sous louis xiv pour savoir si
on pouvait ou ne pouvait pas prendre le
quinquina et donc louis xiv qui faisait
des fièvre récurrente a fini par prendre
du kakina en public et donc à partir du
moment où il a pris du kakina on public
et bien le quinquina est rentré la
pharmacopée française et il a fini par
de la quinine et puis la chloroquine et
puis la drogue thick rouquine qui sont
tous les enfants du quinquina ces
médicaments des plantes
merci
caroline fiat merci monsieur le
professeur d'études recouvrit
affirmerait que l'hydroxyde chloroquine
n'aurait pas d'efficacité avérés contre
lakovic 19 de mémoire vous affirmez vous
même il ya quelques semaines que
l'efficacité n'était pas encore prouvée
mais vous défendiez tout de même la
prescription de cette molécule
car les premiers résultats de vos
recherches s'avéraient concluants et que
ses effets secondaires étaient connus
comment juger cette nouvelle étude
aujourd'hui de nombreux rebondissements
que connaissent les déclarations faites
au sujet de la plus rock in rendent
particulièrement complexe attitude avoir
en termes de politique de santé et donc
je vais prendre exprès l'exemple de
l'essai clinique discovery qui a été
entre guillemets jeu mais bien des
guillemets opposé à votre essai et donc
on nous a annoncé qu'il avait échoué
par faute comment parce que les autres
pays européens ne sont pas entrées dans
l'essai clinique mais beaucoup de
soignants dont moi avons été étonnés
qu'il ne soit pas qu'il n'ait pas
échouer car selon la voie
d'administration et selon la posologie
même une aide soignante pouvait très
vite deviné quel traitement donne
et aux patients et on sait très bien que
dans un essai clinique on n'est pas
censé savoir ce qu'on donne à nos
passions donc ces épisodes ces épisodes
successifs montrent à quel point les
enjeux de pouvoir sont légion au sein de
la ressource et ne servent pas
nécessairement l'intérêt général pouvez
vous nous indiquer sur quels critères
vous vous appuyez pour juger de la
crédibilité d'une étude scientifique les
financements sont il déterminant les
critères sont ils méthodologique la
réputation des scientifiques est elle
impliquée
une autre question avec toute
l'expérience que vous avez eue lors de
la crise sanitaire de lakovic 19
tous les patients que vous avez ausculté
ou avait pris un soin et avec toute
l'expérience que vous avez en ce qui
concerne les épidémies est ce que vous
avez pu constater une efficacité
provenant d'une autre molécule que la
chloroquine sur un stade en particulier
ou sur tous les stades de la maladie si
oui quelles molécules et sur quel stade
actuellement
donc moi vous savez y ait une manière de
d'analysé qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut un
métier qui est celle que l'on connaît
pour essayer de comparer les études
s'appelle les études de méta analyse
nous on a des gens chez nous on fait une
étude de méta analyse qui dissèque
vraiment les différentes études je vous
ai dit et donc on n'a rien on a mis on a
regardé avec hydroxy chloroquine alors
c'était fascinant parce que c'est la
première fois qu'on voyait ça on voyait
que les les réponses étaient de deux
côtés et de deux côtés d'une manière
tranchée ce qui n'est pas compréhensible
voyez c'est à dire c'est bizarre alors
qu'il y avait il ya 4 et ferrando miyagi
à 4 randomisation qui ont été proposées
dont trois étaient en faveur montré que
les roxy chloroquine était supérieur les
autres essais étaient des essais
comparatifs entre la population et les
seuls fc les seules études qui montrait
un effet qui n'étaient pas jusqu'à
l'étude au coverage attend qu'elle soit
il faut attendre que les choses soient
publiés entre déclarations publiques
je reviendrai là dessus et puis la
réalité est un peu différente
le seul qui était de l'autre côté
étaient liés soit au fait c'était des
études qui était uniquement des études
de informatique parfaite par les gens
qui avaient observé les malades
mais les saisies de données
hospitalières du pdci d'accord ou
l'équivalent du big data dont celle du
97e et tout avait les conflits
d'intérêts tout était associé à guilers
donc il y avait un cluster in vous
pouvez le regarder a le premier auteur
et mathieu vignon sairlines et donc ça
montre que on peut analyser parfaitement
les données et on peut ne pas se laisser
trop mais je vais vous donner un exemple
qui qui peut être vous éclairera et j'ai
eu une longue discussion avec les gens
d'une lente est à ce propos une fois
qu'ils sont sortis cette étude la même
semaine dans le land 7
il y avait trois articles étaient rivés
notre article sur 3700 patients sur
lequel nous n'avions aucun mort avec lés
qui pouvait être imputable à une robe
chic lankais sur 3700 personnes
d'accord c'est l'étude qui est
maintenant line qui avait publié il y
avait en même temps cette étude
fantasque de des pieds nickelés
américain donc tout le monde pouvait
voir quelle était pas vrai il y avait
une troisième étude que je connais pas
ce que c'est moi qui en ai fait la
review qui rapportait l'expérience de
tous l'association internationale des
rhumatologues à qui ils ont demandé
quand vous avez une polyarthrite
rhumatoïde et que vous donnez l'érotique
rockin parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
les traite ou vous donner un sulfamide
il y avait neuf cent trente mille
personnes dans un groupe et 350 milles
dans l'autre groupe
il n'y a aucune différence sur les
accidents cardiaques il y en a pas c'est
pas vrai et ils ont rejeté les deux qui
disait qu'il n'y ait pas d'accident et
ils ont publié l'histoire pieds nickelés
donc bon jeu pas très paranoïaque mais
globalement la c'est une situation où on
commence à se poser des questions qui
dépassent sacré voyez c'est à l'étroit
dans la même semaine je vous le jure que
j'ai pire bien un que j'ai envie vous
voulez l'autre que j'ai envoyée a été
rejetée le mien sans révision extérieur
l'autre après que je les retrouvais
parlement et d'autres suggéré la
publication et ils ont gardé le
troisième et qu'ils ont dû rétracter et
tellement été commis qui savait comme
personne ne pourrait croire cette bêtise
ils ont dû le rétracter gamme hockey
parce que
ils ont reçu 20 lettres dont une des
nôtres qui avait accepté avant qu'ils
soient et tracteurs deere écouter
vraiment les problèmes
et puis il ya une pétition qui est parti
du type qui est le plus connu au monde
dans les maladies tropicales qui
s'appelle nick white avec toute l'équipe
d'oxford qui vous pouvez pas publier
chose pareille quand même donc quand
même peut-être que c'est par hasard par
une incompétence terrible mais le land
sept avaient le choix entre trois ils
auraient pu mettre un éditorial
c'est ce que je leur ai dit a posteriori
j'ai fait un article là dessus quand on
est comme ça où on lance pas tout alors
qu'on a les trois articles soit on en
publie deux soit on dit on à un
éditorial ou un comments qui dit le
contraire accor qui dit écoutez c'est
balance et c'est quand même bizarre qui
est 10 % de mortalité personne ne les ai
jamais vus voyez donc de là à dire ça
choix délibéré je n'en sais rien
j'espère que non que c'est juste de la
gauche veut faire un gros pétard on
savait mais il ya quand même franchement
donc il y a eu un problème avec les roxy
croquis le on verra bien laisser
recovery mais c'est assez je m'excuse de
vous dire ça mais quand la décision a
été prise en france de supprimer la
chloroquine le ministre de la santé de
la guinée qui a dit aux français ce que
vous n'êtes pas un peu bizarre vous
parce que l'on connaît bien la
chloroquine on comprend même pas ce que
vous dites on l'utilisé beaucoup plus
que vous et là quand les anglais ont
publié leur méthodologie pour recovery
il ya le groupe des médecins internistes
indien qui a dit écoutez oxford ils ont
un problème parce qu'ils savent pas
utiliser une roxy chloroquine il utilise
à quatre fois la dose et c'est la dose
toxique 2,4 de 2,4 grammes par jour plus
ensuite des doses qui était à fra
thérapeutique donc si vous voulez c'est
pareil à un autre truc dans recovery qui
est qui est très très très très
inquiétant c'est que les corticoïdes
font partie de deux des soins courants
en réanimation pour les pneumonies
sévères et donc de mettre les
corticoïdes non pas dans la décision
médicale malades par malade ce qui se
fait si vous regardez dans les séries
qui sont publiées partout dans le monde
il ya entre 10 et 30% des gens qui
reçoivent des corticoïdes dans les
réanimations en fonction du tableau
clinique de dire non ça on fait de
l'expérimentation là dessus ça revient
sur un des problèmes qu'il ya eu dans ce
pays c'est que les malades
ont été transformés en objets des ces
thérapeutiques et c'était pas ce
qu'était cela merci julien pour rosicky
oui merci madame la présidente vous vous
parliez tout à l'heure de données brutes
et je pense qu'il faut quand même un
pouvoir les interpréter
je reviens sur le compare à dire que
vous avez fait entre les taux de
mortalité parisiens et marseillais
tout d'abord vous interroger sur
l'origine de vos chiffres puisqu'il n'ya
pas de publications à ma connaissance de
deux chiffres par ville pour paris on
peut le comprendre mais pour marseille
on comprend moins vu qu'il s'agit des
bouches du rhône d'autre part évidemment
sachant qu'on a un taux de mortalité
forte heureusement que la plupart du
temps les gens s'en sortent bien
fort heureusement malgré le nombre
tragique de mort évidemment plus on
teste et plus le taux de mortalité
baisse mécaniquement
et puis il est vrai que les populations
ne sont pas les mêmes entre paris et
marseille il est vrai aussi que les
bouches du rhône et la région paca a été
moins touchée que la région parisienne
donc je voudrais voir votre analyse là
dessus deuxième point je reviens quand
même rapidement sur votre départ du du
conseil scientifique parce que je
voulais aborder le sujet de de
l'humilité de la modestie qu'on devrait
tous avoir vis-à-vis de cette maladie et
de l'humain que nous sommes tous dans ce
conseil il y avait aussi une volonté
éthique et je pense qu'il aurait été au
contraire intéressant d'avoir des
données d'un expert tel que vous êtes
pour orienter les décisions sur la
partie humaine et éthiques et si je
trouve dommage c'est plus une
constatation qu'une question enfin
dernière chose je reviens un petit peu
sur ce que disait mon collègue la garde
par rapport à la méthodologie que vous
avez employé
vous avez beaucoup parlé la méthodologie
de devaux consoeurs et confrères mais
c'est vrai que on a un peu l'impression
d'abord que vous avez associés donc
azithromycine et et hydroxy chloroquine
je peux comprendre le président du
conseil de l'ordre sachant qu'on est sûr
de médicaments qui augmente le cul tu es
donc avec des risques cardiaques majeurs
je pense qu'il faut faire attention à ne
pas prescrire sous le coup de l'émotion
qu'on ne pas vous paraphraser mais ce
que je voudrais comprendre c est ce que
vous ne pensez pas que vous avez
finalement été le meilleur ennemi de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine avec c'est ces
études qui avaient des billets
probablement au niveau du protocole et
qui a entraîné manifestement un ressenti
péjoratif dès le départ merci si vous
voulez je peux pour pour répondre à
votre dernière question vous savez je
pense que je m'excuse de vous dire ça
c'est en france on a l'habitude de se
regarder le nombril et encore plus dans
cette ville que partout ailleurs
vous savez il ya des enquêtes de ça
aussi il ya probablement 50% des
médecins dans le monde qui utilisent les
drogues cycloclean et a dit trop de
signes pour traiter l coville je sais
pas si vous voyez le nombre que ça fait
dans le monde d'accord et en france
aussi donc penser que message à part été
entendus il ya des gens qui l'ont pas
entendu il ya beaucoup de gens qui l'ont
entendu et qu'il a entendu et qui en
payent le droit de le faire
parmi ceux qui l'ont entendu donc je
pense qu'il ya deux problèmes qui
dépassent
moi je veux bien que le les anglais
disent qu'ils aiment s angels qu'il faut
tuer le porteur de la douelle je suis
d'accord dont je suis d'accord pour
faire le héros donc bouc émissaire si
vous voulez mais la vraie question est
pas cela et encore une fois moi je j'ai
commencé en disant simplement c'est les
chinois viennent de faire une en train
de finir leur épidémies sont en train de
dire comment ils ont géré leur épidémie
donc on va commencer parce que c'est
comme ça qu'il faut faire quand on est
humble effectivement et qu'en plus on
est sachant plus en étable on va
commencer par regarder ce qu'ils ont eue
l'épidémie tout ce qu'ils ont fait
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait tomber des
scanners low dose en particulier au
genre asymptomatiques qu'ils entreraient
des lésions
c'est eux qui ont trouvé les premières
fibrose ils ont fait des greffes de
poumons sur les fibroses 1 donc il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de choses vote et
publié en chine ses les premiers alors
virus et les premiers à voir tester des
médicaments sur ce virus des deux
premiers c'était la chloroquine mti dire
c'est les premiers alors traiter les
malades
cette communication officielle là dessus
ils ont fait des recommandations qui en
rien à voir avec les autres avec les
nôtres et je suis d'accord avec
ils ont dit écoutez traiter vos malades
mais leur donnait pas plus de trois
antiviraux à la fois parce qu'après
trois sais pas ce que ça fait et dedans
il y avait tout ce qui potentiellement
avait une activité antivirale parce que
leur désir c'était de dire aux gens
soigner soigner soigner soigner je suis
d'accord avec ça donc c'est pas et comme
étant et je passais deux fois la
télévision 4 milliards de do dieter ok
sinon elles sont quand même beaucoup
plus souvent appliquée et stratégies
thérapeutiques avec lequel je suis
d'accord que les pays il faut pour
répondre ensuite avec questions sur
marseille vous savez il faut arrêter de
se regarder le nombril arrêter toute
cette histoire c'est parce que les gens
ici sont crus ils pas qu'ici en europe
de l'ouest les gens sont créés plus
malins ils ont des mauvaises habitudes
c'est là qu'on est mort le plus c'est
l'angleterre la france la belgique et
l'espagne l'italie la rattraper parce
qu'elle a commencé à faire du test
massif a donné du roxy pro keane dès
qu'ils ont compris comment ça se passe
et donc il y avait un départ
extraordinaire actuellement une
mortalité plus basse et peut-être que
l'amérique rattrapera et vous regardez
les quinze premiers pays ces 15 pays
riches du groupe europe etats unis qui
sont les pays qui sont les plus touchés
qui ont le plus de morts
d'accord c'est une vraie question look c
est ce qu on sait encore traiter les
maladies infectieuse aiguë sans que ça
devienne ou un marché où un conflit
politique ou que ça rentre dans la
guerre civile américaine
vous savez bien que c'est pas moi qui
fait que ce foutu un truc mondiale sauf
que la droite finale parce que trump
s'est emparé de ça au milieu d'une
guerre civile américaine entre les pro
et les anti trump ce à quoi j'ai rien à
voir donc
le leu leu il faut pas trop tuer le
messager encore une fois moi je venais
rapporté que des choses très simples
vous devriez plutôt poser la question
comment se fait-il que les chinois ayant
dit écoutez nous la première molécule
que nous avons testé la première sur
lequel nous ayons des résultats c'est la
chloroquine comment se fait-il qu'en
france on n'est jamais mis ça dans un
bras sauf quand il était trop tard pour
le faire
ça c'est une vraie question moi c'est
pas moi le premier a rapporté laplantine
de rapporter ce que les chinois je
dirais que c'est la première porte
ouverte il faut probablement arrêté par
les chinois comme des imbéciles
parce que moi j'ai vu comment ils
travaillent et et puis j'ai pas vu
laboratoires en france qui ressemblait à
ce que j'ai vu en chine
et donc je crois qu'ils sont bien merci
je dois pas laisser penser que les
médecins n'ont pas soigner en france et
que les chercheurs n'ont pas cherché il
ne continue pas de chercher donc on va
continuer évidemment être les questions
de mes collègues mais je voulais juste
mettre ce bémol donc monsieur pour
répondre à celui de vos questions c'est
pour ça que j'ai dit encore une fois il
faut regarder le la mortalité brut par
million d'habitants ce qui est un point
donc ça c'était un phénomène qui est
relativement indépendant des tests qui
dépend de l'épidémiologie mais j'ai dit
quelque chose que je suis en profite
pour vous répéter en regardant en
revanche la structure de la mortalité
est témoin de la qualité des soins
c'est à dire que si vous avez dans un
même échantillon de 100 personnes
vous avez 9% 8 % de morts de moins de 65
ans ou s'il avait le double ça signifie
qui s'est passé quelque chose dans la
qualité de la prise en charge et du son
et ça c'est indépendant de la fréquence
c'est indépendant des tests sommes
d'accord et on a assez donné
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
professeur deux questions la première
comment expliquer que certaines régions
en france aient pu être plus touchés que
d'autres
je vous dise en qualité de président du
groupe agir ensemble mais également en
qualité de député mulhouse qui étaient
particulièrement touchés vous déclariez
récemment que certaines personnes
pouvaient avoir une immunité peut être
naturel ce que vous pourriez nous en
dire plus et le professeur delfraissy
disait ici la semaine dernière que l'on
pouvait aussi avoir des super
contaminateur c'est à dire des personnes
qui avaient une charge virale très forte
et dont le cas échéant les gouttelettes
de pouvait rester en aérosols dans l'air
et contaminer un nombre beaucoup plus
important de personnes est ce que vous
pouvez nous éclairer sur ce premier
point je veux vous dire le peu que je
sais et si vous voulez les gens qui vous
expliquent qu'ils ont compris quelque
chose s'en vont au delà de ce qui est la
connaissance générale commence à tousser
les maladies d'écosystèmes
les maladies infectieuses d'écosystèmes
personnel et d'écosystèmes général on
comprend pas du tout moi je m'intéresse
depuis les années j'ai même fait des
numéros spéciaux dans la littérature là
dessus sur le phénomène saisonnier
je comprends absolument pas par exemple
éclipsé la caisse maladie très grave
c'est plus fréquent septembre octobre
pourquoi je sais toujours pas pourquoi
pourquoi est ce que nous la grippe c'est
que influenza ça va ça vient je crois de
alfredo l'affluence du froid c'avait été
décrit je crois que c'est fracassant
elle écrit ça parce que ça survenait
pendant l'hiver d'accord et donc pour
nous la grippe a toujours été une
affection divers mais on pensait ça
jusqu'à encore relativement peu de temps
parce qu'on a étudié ça dans les pays
tempérés dans les pays tempère il ya un
univers mais c'est je le travaille
beaucoup en afrique il ya des grilles
pour toute l'année et en a plus la
saison de pluie mais personne ne peut
expliquer ça et rien toute l'année
d'accord et il ya des choses des choses
extrêmement étrange et on a mon
travaille beaucoup avec les les migrants
qui vont en arabie saoudite
ouais on a même eu une contrôle que
l'arabie saoudite pour essayer de
comprendre les échanges de microbes qui
sont pas ce que vous avez vu comment ça
se passe où fait rage de la mecque
maloyas une densité humaine c'est pas ce
qui s'est passé à mulhouse c'est un truc
3 millions qui tournent ensemble c'est
un truc qui fait qui est impressionnant
eh bien on teste tous les gens de main
on a fait une grosse étude sur 2000
personnes avec le port d'où venaient les
microbes et nous on teste depuis dix ans
et figure trick faisais chez moi qui qui
teste tous les gens qui partent et tous
les gens qui reviennent donc sur
volontaire on leur fait un prélèvement
écouvillon pharyngés ils se font même un
auto prélèvement des collectes à l'avant
après on regarde ce avec quoi ils
reviennent regarde ce qui se passe et on
a des gens qui reviennent avec la grippe
parce qu'il rencontre le
la fête de l'aïd a été ces dernières
années plutôt l'été et donc ils
reviennent ils rencontrent là bas des
gens qui sont dans une période
saisonnière où il ya de la grippe
ils reviennent avec la grippe il n'y a
pas de cas secondaires even dans l'été
la grippe il n'y a pas de cas
secondaires d'accord parce que les
conditions écologiques ne sont pas
favorables au fait qu'est des cas
secondaires
donc on a une théorie pour essayer
d'expliquer mais c'est extrêmement
complexe donc c'est pour ça que vous
expliquer ce que va être la répartition
d'une épidémie tout ce qu'on sait c'est
que les épidémies dans l'histoire
l'humanité ça toujours commencer sa seat
arrêter à un moment donc c'est même les
pires qu'on connaît on a l'impression
que maintenant que c'était tout le temps
mais ce n'est pas tout le temps des
vagues épidémiques à variole vale vale
épidémique ne sais pas pourquoi après
tout le monde peut avoir une explication
10 ans et le niveau d'immunité général
etc
mais on est et on n'en sait rien c'est
une vraie question est donc ça explique
pourquoi
d'abord il ya des phénomènes le le sarc
par exemple pour donner un exemple parce
que c'est quand même pas un virus qui
est très loin
toutes les études qui avaient été faites
sur le savent a été fait énormément
d'études ont été faites à hong kong sur
deux hôtels dans lequel est truqué laon
c'est là qu'on a dit tiens il ya un
super contaminateur c'est un type qui a
prêté sa cave au milieu du couloir et
puis tous les gens qui étaient attachons
à taper ça donc il ya eu il a contaminé
on a estimé 100 personnes alors que le
taux de ré le ratio de contamination
moyen de 2,3 donc c'est de là qu'est née
l'idée du sper contaminateur et donc on
sait toujours pas ce qui s'est passé
sauf que les vomissements sont beaucoup
plus contaminant que les autres mais que
mécanique parce que le volume 2 sur
beaucoup plus grand real a beaucoup plus
mais dix ans après le sar ça a été
rapportée un très bon journal l'étude de
la distribution de sa part des
techniques sérologique spécifique du
sart ce et on s'est rendu compte qu'il
ya des jeunes qui avaient été affectés
jusqu'à 100 mètres de l'hôtel sans qu'on
l'ait jamais vu et sans qu'on comprenne
comment c'est possible
d'accord dont il voulait notre degré
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
moi j'étais un tel partisans de observé
tester observé tester observé qu'on n'a
pas été déçu retrouvez tout ce qu'on
voulait plein de choses parce que si
vous voulez quand vous êtes face à une
maladie inconnue toute opinion est
fausse et donc il faut commencer par
observer collecter les données et même
une fois qu'on a collecté le maximum de
données
il ya un certain nombre de choses qui
est tant mieux parce que comme vous
dites et chercheurs continuent à
chercher et donc il faut
du travail pour ceux qui viendront après
mais je peux vous dire que pour
l'épidémiologie des maladies
infectieuses du travail il en reste et
c'est il ya une immense partie de ça je
vais vous dire vous savez d'où ça vient
le vous avez l'idée du d'où ça vient le
il faut se laver les mains pour les
affections respiratoires
c'est commencer mais je peux vous dire
il ya à peu près un temps je découvre ça
j'ai review et pour le 27 un papier de
gens qui avaient fait une étude ans au
pakistan en faisant par bloc au pakistan
des gens à qui donner des savants on a
refait la même étude au sénégal on a
tous la même chose des blogs de gens qui
donnait des savons
se laver tous les jours et puis il
vérifier que les gens se laver les mains
de tous les jours et prenez un bain une
fois par semaine cela avait une fois par
semaine et il cherchait pour ça quelque
chose qui était très logique qu'ils
étaient et gaston un terrible parce
qu'on sait que les gastro entérites
vous connaissez beaucoup de maladies
qu'on l'appelle manu portet qui sont
paix qu'on appelle le père etc allez
donc c'était ça qu'on cherchait
et comme contrôle ils ont pris les
pneumonies et ils ont une énorme
surprise
il y avait des pneumonies diminuer
autant que les gastro entérites et c'est
la première fois qu'on a vu qu'on
d'éviter les pneumonies ans seulement et
que c'était avec la vectorisation massif
des infections respiratoires
c'est les mains etc d'une découverte par
hasard et donc avec nos méthodologistes
on n'aurait pas pu le voir parce que
c'était pas des objectifs primaires de
voir la diminution des pneumonies et la
plupart des grandes découvertes y font
par ailleurs
en réalité c'est pas des choses qu'on a
prévu sinon les auraient testé avant
merci alors martin wagner
merci madame la présidente professeur
alors vous nous avez dit que vous étiez
en contact régulièrement avec les plus
hautes instances de ce pays
mais avez-vous eu l'impression d'être
entendus ou d'être compris pourquoi état
d'urgence
le 23 mars suite à cet état d'urgence
deux décrets 25 et 26 mars qui ne
réserve l'hydroxyde chloroquine cas des
stades tardifs hospitalier avec toute
une grade graduation d'étapes cliniques
graves
or c'est pas du tout votre protocole
puisque d'equihen patients testés
positifs vous
vous mettez en place la bithérapie ou
tel que vous allez nous leur ai expliqué
mais peut-être qu'un autre message était
plus entendu parce que dès la réunion du
5 mars de près conseil scientifique
les laboratoires sont présents et le
chef de service de bichat yazdan
yazdanpanah qui n'a que le mot rênes d y
virent à la bouche est présent également
alors peut-être était-il un message et
qu'ils étaient plus écouté que vous
qu'en pensez vous je vais vous demander
de finir toutes vos questions parce que
là on a encore beaucoup de demandes
après donc c'est pas possible où on
avait dit au départ c'est parce que en
route ça c'est ça a bougé mais dans vos
deux minutes d'accord c'est pour
faciliter les réponses du professeur
autre question concernant votre étude la
dernière dont vous avez publié
l'abstract avez vous une idée de quand
elle va sortir parce que peut-être que
ça nous éclairerait définitivement sur
le protocole à suivre
et peut-être ray rhdp remettre en france
si vous étiez entendu aux médecins de
première ligne au médecin traitant
cette possibilité d'utiliser ou pas
cette molécule selon les résultats que
dont vous allez nous parler et donc
cette liberté de prescription en france
qui quelque part a été interdite et dans
la région où je suis élue comme comme
monsieur brecht
la problématique était que des patients
ont sursaturé les établissements et je
pense qu'on aurait pu éviter cette en
effet cette ce transfert en
hospitalisation
là encore si les médecins de première ni
avait eu le droit de dépister d'isoler
de confiner peut-être mais surtout de
traiter ce qui a manqué complètement
dans la stratégie
il me semble merci professeur alors de
deux choses le l'arrêté du 1er arrêté du
ministre n'étaient plus subtil que ça
pour pour répondre autres qui mettait
notamment
donc c'était s'était notamment aux
formes plus graves
c'était notamment donc ce qui fait je
les appelais et m'a dit 'il m'a marqué
notamment donc ça veut dire que
notamment donc c'est une subtilité et
qui permettait ce qu'ils lisaient pas
qu'ils aient pas l'exégèse du test de du
texte de dire que les formes qui n'était
pas grave ne pouvait pas de tester donc
je continue à les traiter en accord avec
l'arrêté le la deuxième chose je suis
d'accord je pense que l'environnement
d'abord moi quand j'ai commencé à
discuter que militaire m'a tout de suite
dit celui qui va gérer les essais ce qui
va faire un truc cia cela début le début
des débuts et dieu le début il m'a parlé
que du anticipé dès le début avant même
que la sensibilité de décès liés au
virus soit soit soient testés donc moi
je dis sur le sahara s'il ya un parti
mais il ya un antibiotiques par voie
injectable s'appelle à tarbes au cid qui
marche bien qu'ils avaient été testés
pour kelly un brevet donc il ya des
solutions alternatives
et pas que ça donc ça c'est un point je
suis très sceptique sur la qualité de
l'environnement pour les médicaments et
pour les choix thérapeutiques du
ministre je pense que son environnement
n'est qu'au comme comme je voulais dit
l'ancien directeur de l'année scène mais
l'ancien président de la chasse ont
exprimé publiquement leur désaccord avec
leurs successeurs
et je suis d'accord avec les
prédécesseurs donc je pense que et je
crois que c'est très important si je
peux l'exprimer comme ça à ma manière
vous me pardonnerez vous savez ces
ministres effectivement des problèmes
c'est qui et il reste pas très longtemps
mais théoriquement ils ont une garde
prétorienne si vous voulez de directeur
de très très grande qualité
si les directeurs qui sont hors sont pas
très grandes qualités sont pas ne font
pas mûres entre le le flux
d'informations alarmantes permanent
auquel est soumis le mini ce ci a pas de
mur c'est la personne qui traite les
données d'une manière efficace et
sérieuse alors le ministre est exposé
d'une manière
c'est insupportable je pense ça je pense
que donc il faudra c'est une des choses
demandées à l'avenir je pense qu'il
faudra être extrêmement attentif à la
qualité des gens qui sont mis en place
pour constituer la première ce que
j'appelle la garde prétorienne si vous
voulez la première sécurité des
ministres pour assurer leur qualité de
façon à ce que le ministre ne soit pas
submergés d'informations inquiétantes
qui ne se révèlent jamais vrai parce que
tout ça n'a jamais été publié après moi
je peux vous dire que les informations
qui ont circulé
le nombre de morts prétendu vous le
savez je crois vous avez fait un truc on
disait il ya eu tant de morts avec l'edd
roxy coquine et temps d'arrêt cardiaque
et après il restait rien du tout quand
ils étaient analysées c'était pas vrai
mais c'était transmis directement et
sans décoffrage au ministre la santé qui
étaient affolés par ce flux
d'information affolé il faut faire
attention que la garde prétorienne
ebener et de la connaissance
parce que sinon on affole les gens en
place et après ils prennent des
décisions liées au niveau d'information
qu'ils ont et quand même si je crois que
le ministre écoutent ce que je dis après
ce n'est pas la seule information qu'il
est là c'est pas moi qui suis en
permanence al conseillers et à lui
donner des conseils donc si les conseils
de proximité sont faits par des gens qui
n'ont pas les nerfs ou qui n'ont pas la
compétence c'est un véritable problème
messieurs professeur vous portez un
constat sévère et est grave puisqu'au
décrivez un peu un ministre sous
influence avec des directeurs quelques
ailes directeur vous ciblez aujourd'hui
sur cette faiblesse clairement pour les
médicaments c'est le directeur l'asm et
puis le président de la haute autorité
de santé avait clairement c'est eux qui
ont pris ces décisions c'est vrai que le
conseiller du de maladies infectieuses
et là aussi à des conflits d'intérêts
que seulement sérieux dans la haute
autorité de santé que vous pouvez
regarder sur internet aussi c'est pas
compliqué tout ça donc il y a là des
réflexions avoir encore une fois de fond
sur je dis pas que le ministre est sous
influence islamiste ne peut pas ne pas
être influencé un cabinet qui a pas
choisi la des directeurs qui n'a pas
choisi il arrive au milieu d'une crise
donc si les gens qui représentent la
force institutionnel n'ont pas la
capacité de le protéger et au contraire
lui font croire que pour le protéger il
faut qu'ils interdisent des choses qui
vont tuer les gens bien entendu on a eu
des situations qui finissent par être
paradoxal où l'on finit par être seul au
monde quand même à penser ça donc à
prendre des mesures aussi radicales
donc je pense que ça doit amener
sûrement une réflexion je pense que vous
devriez vous la connaissez bien moi je
dis on devrait voir mais attendez faut
organiser qui est pourquoi est ce que
les prédécesseurs ont un point de vue
radicalement différent de ce qu'ils
auront juste succès des trois îles
exprimé en public et puis s'est pas
excusé robustesse et une robustesse que
tout le monde connaît merci mais se sont
forgés merci madame la présidente
monsieur professeur déjà je souhaite
vous dire tout toute mon admiration et l
est et l'admiration de beaucoup de
français pour votre pouvoir transparence
pour votre travail acharné vous êtes un
faiseur et c'est vrai sachant est un
faiseur et et c'est assez rare en france
aujourd'hui pour être pour être souligné
tamer préliminaire je souhaitais juste
savoir parce que vous venez de quand
même porter des accusations sur la nes m
sur la chaise est-ce que vous parlez de
la haute autorité de santé ou du haut
conseil de la santé publique
je continue laquelle à la question si je
comprends madame la présidente je vais
aussi aller dans votre champ sur les
dents sur les dangers de consolidation
des fabricants de temps dans la
pharmacie que dans le les matériaux in
vitro puisque vous avez parlé des
ruptures très active extraction de
qiagen
mais on a fait là on a eu le même
problème de blocage avec thermo fisher
est en fait en creusant on se rend
compte que quelques gênes et hameaux
fischer on sent la même société avec
même propriétaire si donc là c'est vrai
dans la pharma comme c'est vrai dans le
reste des dispositifs médicaux
moi je sais que ce que ce qui me pose
souci vous avez parlé des lazarets et
finalement en fait le confinement on a
fait des lazare et improvisé alors que
personne ne reconnaît personne et que
personne n'était lépreux et finalement
vous nous parlez de séquelles
aujourd'hui donc et donc c'est à dire
qu'on est dit aux gens restez chez vous
et il semble que même chez les gens qui
survivent à rds sévères ces nombreux
respiratoires sévères et séquelles
neurologiques chantant et pulmonaires
donc moi je souhaiterais que avoir votre
avis sur cette attitude de finalement de
confiner à la hâte et puis d'avoir
peut-être négligé des effets à long
terme de la part de la pathologie sur 7
sur cette base est peut-être peut-être
pourquoi moi je comprends votre logique
de tester massivement avec votre
traitement à simple et peu coûteux c'est
à dire de diminuer aussi le portage
virale et donc la contagiosité
alors est ce que une interne hâtive
idéal utt donc de tester massivement et
d'accompagner cette démarche par ce
traitement simple et peu coûteux parce
que finalement il y avait tout ce qu'il
fallait pour notamment des pays pauvres
on ne passe d'un pays pauvres à voir
avec des signes cliniques qui permettait
de diagnostiquer la maladie avec une
grande sensibilité d'une grande
spécificité comme la noce miel agouazi
et à la fois des traitements existants
est simple et des démarches finalement
que tout a donc tout à chacun aurait pu
saisir et pourquoi
pourquoi avoir manqué cela dans nos pays
développés merci encore une fois il est
possible que j'ai cru comprendre que
vous étiez d'origine coréenne jeu encore
et c'est pareil les recommandations
étaient donner quelque chose aux
patients dont les drogues cycloclean
donc c'est pas s'il n'y a pas que les
pays pauvres il ya les pays d'extrême
orient relier l'europe est isolé dans ce
l'europe et les états unis sont isolés
dans cette stratégie qui a été une
stratégie de de ne pas traiter de ne pas
traiter même et donc la vraie question
que vous posez qui a été probablement la
raison pour laquelle fin ou moins une
des raisons pour lesquelles a été levée
d'une manière absolument insensé la
toxicité de l'adle hydroxy chloroquine
et l'azithromycine était que le bon sens
vous voulez écouter on sais pas jusqu'à
quel point ça marche mais il faut faire
quelque chose pour les malades
c'est ce qu'on a l'habitude de faire
tous quand même on n'a pas commencé à
faire de la médecine depuis un siècle
ça fait très longtemps que
médecine la médecine dont on donne
quelque chose on soigne les malades et
d'ailleurs c'était une des choses si on
avait fait ça c'est pas seulement le
médicament c'est tout le soin qui est
autour très tôt on s'est rendu compte
qu'il fallait donner des anticoagulants
au début parce qu'ils avaient des
embolies nous le seul mort jeune que
l'on a eue avec 59 ans est mort parce
qu'il a fait une embolie pulmonaire et
qu'on l'avait pas antico régulier parce
qu'on savait pas à l'époque qu'il
fallait en tant qu à deux les gens donc
donc au fur et à mesure on apprenait
bien entendu si on fait des tests de
saturation en oxygène
ça coûte 20 euros est de savoir si on
s'est d'abord un testeur pour voir la
saturation en oxygène
si on fait la saturation à l'oxygène et
qu'on voit que les gens une saturation
qui est en tout cas 95 ou en dessous
bien les prends l'hôpital en les oxygen
où les oxygen amusant on fait quelque
chose on n'attend pas qui sont en
détresse respiratoire parce qu ils le
sentiront pas avant la détresse
respiratoire détresse respiratoire
donc il ya je crois beaucoup et même si
vous voulez quand on renvoie les gens
qui sont positifs et qu'ils savent
qu'ils sont positifs d'avoir tous ceux
qui sont négatifs sont contents
et puis ceux qui sont positifs ont une
manière de se comporter dans leur propre
famille qui n'est pas de même nature que
ceux qui ne sont pas positifs ils
reviennent se faire tester jusqu'au
moment où ils sont négatifs et donc il
le s'isole dans leurs champs mais
s'enferme ils savent qu'ils représentent
un risque pour leurs familles c'est pas
la même nature que de dire écoutez on
sait pas qui c'est qui est positif et le
supplice il pas surtout quand vous
pensez si les gens pas de fièvre qui
tousse pas ce qui était le cas de la
majorité des cas quand même hein comment
est ce qu'ils savent qu'ils sont
contagieux pour leurs familles le savent
pas donc si vous leur dites vous êtes
contagieux
vous pouvez penser qu'ils vont avoir un
comportement nature différente pour
protéger leurs familles et donc vous
allez diminuer le risque de contagion
même s'ils sont confinés donc je pense
encore fort mais je pense que tout le
monde
le croit maintenant que la clé c'est la
détection et ça alors là en revanche il
ya des études si vous voulez qu'ils
montrent que le nombre de cas le nombre
de cas l'extension de la maladie et la
mortalité est lié au monde de capter ça
on a ça le le maximum étant l'islande
qui adorent tas était le plus bas et qui
a fait le plus de tests par habitant
donc ça on sait que c'est une brique et
ensuite la clé 2 est ce que dans une
situation comme celle là il vaut mieux
donner des médicaments ou ne rien donner
la question se pose rapidement encore
une fois de savoir mais attendez vous
êtes en train de donner un poison mortel
à des gens quand encore une fois moi je
sais que il faut tuer le messager mais
je n'ai pas compris comment ça pouvait
déclencher un tel scénario de trucs ce
truc tu tout le monde quand on parlait
de deux des médicaments les plus
prescrits dans l'histoire de l'humanité
comme on comment on est arrivé à dire
que ces trucs-là avait toxicité aussi
incroyable alors que encore une fois
aucune en 2019 elle était donnée sans
ordonnance et après on les trouvait même
plus on n'est même plus le droit la
prescrire donc c'était ça pose des
problèmes et y compris parce que les
gens qui avaient d'autres maladies qui
avec des cyclos qui n'est pas la voir
dans les pharmacies
comment on est passé d'un côté à l'autre
sans que personne c'est vous qui devez
vous poser la question mais qu'est ce
qui s'est passé pourquoi ce médicament
qu'est ce qui a changé dans ce
médicament pour que la france passe de
on n'a même pas besoin d'une ordonnance
a même avec une redondance on vous le
donne plus comme si il ya quelque chose
qui s'est passé quand même c'est pas moi
qui ai fait ça c'est pas mal mais c'est
pas parce que j'ai dit peut-être dû bien
hydroxyque horrible et je suis le diable
et certains le disent des sondages
disent le contraire
c'est ce qui vaut d'être auditionné
parfois jean pierre door merci madame la
présidente
oui ce professeur je retrouve le même
professeur raoul qu'en 2012 nous étions
croisés bien vous avez expliqué vos
critiques envers la haute autorité de
santé envers l'agencé nationale du
médicament
mais je sais que vous avez aussi
critiqué l' oms en là
traitant de pyromanes de la planète dans
le domaine des épidémies et bien entendu
aussi le haut conseil de santé publique
donc j'aimerais savoir pourquoi et plus
raisonnablement est-ce que vous avez
saisi le ministre lorsqu'il a déclaré
que à dépistage large n'aurait aucun
sens au niveau médical et au niveau
scientifique
c'était sa phrase et enfin dernière
question que pensez vous de laisser de
la d'exams états zone en tant qu'anti
inflammatoires nouveaux dont on parle
depuis quelques jours ou quelques
semaines
merci c'est pour ça que je vois que vous
sourit beaucoup on inclut les nouveaux
parce que nous avons tous les deux jeux
quel point les nouveaux bien sûr les
mêmes débats d'ailleurs sur l'usagé le
premier staff de médecine auquel j'ai
assisté à l'époque où il y avait un
hôpital de maladies infectieuses à paris
ils étaient hôpital claude bernard
j'étais allé à sa batterie assister au
staff et le débat était déjà ce qu'il
faut donner dans ces cas l'accord teaser
n'est pas là ou pas la cortisone donc
c'est un débat qui est très ancien qui
est très compliqué parce que probable il
ya des indications spécifiques qui sont
et qui sont à choisir par le médecin
individuellement on peut pas faire des
tous les essais qui ont été faits avec
la dexaméthasone ou avec les autres
partis amen
hélas si vous regardez bien le peu qui
est en train de sortir c'est qu'il faut
pas donner de cortisone à des gens qui
n'ont pas de couverture pour leurs
maladies infectieuses et donc quand ils
ont fait ça s'est aggravé
donc c'est à dire la première phase que
je vous décrivais qui est purement
virales ont été cortisone à grave parce
que vous baissez défenses immunitaires
là où vous en avez besoin là où les
défenses immunitaires deviennent folles
il est vraisemblable que ça rend un
service sap a été vraiment quantifier et
dans dans les sd et racé au kouhaku par
exemple les gens qui ont plus de 75 ans
leur donne pas de cortisone parce que ça
peut faire pire que le truc tout ça
c'est de la médecine la cortisone c'est
quand même un vieux médicament qui a été
très utilisé le jeu je veux pas faire
encore une fois le l'exégèse des textes
ministériels parce que je crois que dans
la pression et avec les informations de
sources multiples dont jeu
j'assume ma part de responsabilité c'est
difficile d'avoir une ligne continue
quand le vent souffle dans tous les sens
ces marins qui parle pour pour l'eau et
mais si vous voulez je pense il est
possible que nous ayons eue en europe de
l'ouest des réactions de jeu je pense
que nous sommes en europe de l'ouest
nous sommes aux nous sommes devenus des
sociétés très fragile très réactive aux
crises y compris quand ces crises ne
sont pas réels et que si j'ai toujours
tenté d'être rassurant parce que je
crois que la peur est très mauvaise
conseillère
je pense qu'il faut agir dans le calme
sans peur et que donc de soulever la
peur ou de dramatiser donc fois que j'ai
parlé des choses j'ai tenté d'en de
prendre l'hypothèse la plus basse parce
que je pense que c'est mieux
je pense que c'est quitte à assumer gens
disent écoutez c'est plus grave que ce
que vous disiez je les assume
entièrement mais si vous regardez le
moment où effectivement le le feu a été
mis à la plana la planète c'est au
moment de l'épidémie de e année puis de
iba et puis un peu plus en chine
en tout ça fait à peu près 6000 morts
tout ça à la fin de l'année en chine si
quelqu'un arrive va voir la différence
avec 6 millions et fort on verra pas la
différence
donc il ya eu une sur réaction de la
chine parce que la chine avait été
accusé pendant longtemps à l'om est
d'avoir caché le sarce et donc parce que
la chine donc la chine a réagi ça en
construisant des effectivement des
hôpitaux centres de recherche absolument
hallucinant extraordinaire et là mon
sens elle a eu une communication
excessive du fait de sept premiers
épisodes de sas pour laquelle était
accusé de dissimuler les faits si vous
voulez en lançant une alerte qui tout
bien analysé a posteriori est totalement
disproportionnée par rapport à la
populace l ubaye c'est la population de
la france est le nombre de morts en
chine c'est le nombre de morts dans
l'île de france c'est ça la réalité
donc si vous voulez la halle alerte
initiale est une alerte qui est
entièrement disproportionnée
vous croyez aux chiffres chinois
moi si vous voulez je vois pas de raison
de ne pas croire aux chiffres chinois je
vois pas ce que vous voulez pourquoi les
chinois mentir et plus dans quelque
chose dont au contraire ils ont dit que
c'était ils ont plutôt eu tendance mon
point de vue a amplifié le phénomène
pour dire regardez comme on est sérieux
regardée qu'en tant pis d'ailleurs tout
le monde à tourner tous cherchent ils
d'ailleurs jeu là aussi je ne veux pas
faire de balises parce que je pense que
c'est pas vrai mais enfin je pense que
le plus grand bénéficiaire de la crise
au mondial j'ai une arme parce qu'on a
tout acheté là bas à feu non comme on
sait pas faire une facture peut pas tout
acheter en chine goal merci david habib
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
professeur
bonjour je vais vous poser une première
question qui est oui ou non et vous
verrez après je me permettrai de faire
un commentaire vous la poste vous at on
demandé une déclaration publique
d'intérêts lorsque vous êtes rentré au
conseil scientifique vos conseils
scientifiques
oui d'accord je le dis parce que à
l'aller coûte 2 je suis pas médecin et l
écoute des des différentes interventions
il me semble que madame la présidente on
doit une commission denquête c'est aussi
ça il me semble que sur cette question
des questions de cette question des
conflits d'intérêts il faut qu'on puisse
travailler davantage et puis peut-être
que il faudra peut-être faire une autre
commission d' enquête sur les conflits
d'intérêts dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique mais on s'éloigne un peu
de de ce qui nous amène aujourd'hui
deuxième point j'arrive pas très bien
comprendre monsieur le professeur
le 11 mai le président de la république
disait nous n'allons pas tester tous les
français cela n'aurait aucun sens et
cette phrase elle a été reprise par tous
les fonctionnaires de l'état
moi j'ai va se reconnaître la déléguée
de la rs dans mon département le plus
beau celui des pyrénées atlantiques qui
disait alors que je lui parlais des
tests sérologiques avec une une autorité
définitive monsieur le député ça ne sert
à rien ce n'est pas validée en france et
ce discours là on l'a entendu pendant
toute cette période
pourtant le même emmanuel macron qui
disait ça ne sert à rien de tester vous
a reconnu que a reconnu que vous avez
raison sur la question des tests
alors moi j'arrive pas à comprendre ça
il l'a dit le 28 mai qu'est-ce qui a
fait que entre le 11 mai le 28 mai le
prix dans la république ait pu changer
d'avis sur votre analyse et sur la
question des tests si je vous dis ça et
je vais conclure madame la présidente
c'est que au delà du 38 morts il ya un
sentiment général d'un fiasco en termes
de communication terrible dans ce
dossier et qu'il nous faudra et le
rapporteur est là pour ça il nous faudra
nous appesantir aussi sur les allers et
retours des pouvoirs publics sur la
question des masques sur la question des
tests sur la question des respirateurs
parce que nous avons perdu du temps en
changeant d'avis si souvent si c'est une
question que je vous réponde jeu en tout
cas j'ai un commentaire je suis un
commentaire aussi nous vivons
l'écosystème si vous me permettez dans
lequel vous vivez vous et le même
écosystème que l'écosystème des médias
en grande partie au moins pour les gens
qui sont aux affaires et ça amène une
vitesse de réactivité qui à mon avis est
un problème et donc je vois moi je
encore une fois je ne regarde pas tes
vision je goûte par radio je lis
rarement journaux donc je ne suis pas
perturbé c'est probablement me demande
si je suis perturbée quand on dit des
horreurs je m'en fous que je les ai pas
entendus
en plus j'ai interdit à tous les gens
autour de moi de m'en parler donc
simples peuvent lire tant qu'on veut sur
moi je vous le dis ça m'indiffère ces
légendes conseil vous dites que j'en
dise du mal de vous portez pas plainte
j'ai même pas qui c'est mais je ne les
connais pas donc je pense qu'il y à une
sollicitation trop importante justement
de communication et que cet excès de
communication du à la communication
moi je peux pas vous dire mais
nombre de gens qui viennent
photographier nombre de sollicitations
que je peux avoir
boyer pas souvent parler la télévision
je refuse comme en plus je le refuse de
venir ici pieuvre et provincial moi je
ne viens pas sur les plateaux de
télévision jean restera le visage je
suis aussi avare que possible parce que
je pense que d'abord plus en parle plus
on dit bêtise et plus il ya de chances
qu'on dise des bêtises statistiquement
ces statistiques
donc il faut pas trop parler parce que
la chance que l'on dise des bêtises
devient de plus en plus important en
plus en part et comme qui fusent et on
oublie ce qu'on a dit quelques jours
avant si on parle tous les jours
il finit par y avoir quelqu'un comme
vous qui disent vous avez dit ça comme
tel jour 10 à tel jour et c'est pas
exactement la même chose
merci josaine corps de loups merci
madame la présidente simplement deux
petites questions professeur il y a des
dizaines de milliers de patients qui
prennent quotidiennement d'hydroxyde
rockin pour des maladies articulaires
d'origine inflammatoires j'en ai moi
même délivré pendant plus de 30 ans en
tant que pharmacien est ce que nous
savons aujourd'hui si ces patients
étaient moins atteints par le
coronavirus ou non parce que ce travail
a été réalisé
et puis ma deuxième question je vais
revenir sur l'interdiction de
prescription hydroxyque eurokin nous
avons auditionné il ya quelques jours le
professeur salomon je les ai interrogés
à cet effet il m'a expliqué que la
médiatisation de l'hydroxyde chloroquine
étant importante et risquait d'y avoir
une automédication qui était très
augmentée et donc des risques inhérents
en fait lorsqu'on décortique les
chiffres on s'aperçoit que les risques
effectivement vous l'avez vous l'avez
dit ne sont pas aussi important que cela
mais surtout je m'interroge si
effectivement nous voulions pas lié à
cette automédication qui aurait pu être
développé pourquoi à ce moment ne pas
listé la molécule pourquoi interdire la
prescription aux médecins et je voulais
avoir votre avis qu'est ce qui peut
justifier aujourd'hui l'interdiction de
prescription de cette molécule par des
médecins donc comme vous le dites c'est
une molécule banal moi personnellement
je vous ai donné mon avis
je ne je ne comprends pas que l'on
puisse interdire de molécules qui a été
encore une fois l'année dernière a été
prescrit 36 millions de comprimés qui
ont été distribués en france étaient
brutalement sans ordonnance et du jour
au lendemain on décide que l'on peut
même plus délivrés sur ordonnance
je ne le comprends pas ce jeu là pour
page 10 je ne cherche pas la vie et je
vois là donc je vous le dis à vous je me
suis gardé de vous savez alors ça bien
sûr et je m'en suis ouvert là j'ai le
devoir de vous répondre donc je vous
réponds mais je n'ai jamais recommandé
ce traitement parce que je n'ai pas le
droit de recommander un traitement qui
est hors mm je peux pas leur commande et
je peux dire ce que je fais donc mais je
peux pas vous le commandez et de j'ai
jamais aux commandes
si vous écoutez bien ce que je dis je
dis ce que je fais je vous recommande
pas c'est peut-être une nuance mais
c'est une nuance qu'elles sont
importants ce qui est bien entendu je
pense que j'ai le devoir d'informer les
gens et donc oui je forme les gens ce
que j'informe après je m'excuse message
informe les gens quand on a un papier
qui est en train d'être publiés qui
devient public donc il n'y a pas de je
n'ai pas de raison de ne pas informer de
travaux que nous avons faits qui sont
publiques
je n'ai pas fait j'ai pas annoncer qu
effectivement lentilles l6 était en
train de bouleverser la thérapeutique à
paris je viens de lire une méta-analyse
parce que quand on est dans le domaine
était bien sûr on sait les choses un peu
avant les autres moi je review fait
trois-quatre papier sur le co vide ou
qu'on en voit de toutes les revues du
monde par jour donc souffler tout ce qui
se passe relativement précocément et
j'ai revu encore très récemment une
méta-analyse dont on parlait sur le
petit corps monoclonal que monsieur
hirsch a annoncé comme étant un miracle
thérapeutique sur lequel il ya aucune
différence
actuellement tous les essais qui m'a été
fait dans le monde donc faut faire
attention quand on annonce et chose
qu'on les annonce au moment où papier
est accepté ou déposer quelque part
c'est qu'on peut déposer les papiers
maintenant nous on aurait compris ont
déposé sur notre site de manière à ce
qu'il soit
les gens puissent vérifier que ce que
vous dites ne soit pas soit je suis en
désaccord avec les annonces que cas
effet prématurément recovery où ça aussi
avant que le papier soit disponible donc
il faut que le papier soit disponible au
moment que les gens puissent voir ou
puisse voir l'abstract de ce que vous
avez fait au moment où vous l'annoncer
merci principes scientifiques
valérie rapaud oui merci madame la
présidente monsieur professeur j'aurais
cinq questions rapides
vous avez nommé rapid vous avez parlé de
l'immunité croisé ducobu de lakovic 19
avec d'autres coronavirus qui
expliquerait la protection des enfants
vis-à-vis de la copie de 19
est ce que on pourra évaluer cette
immunité croisés pour le reste de la
population
deuxième question vous nous avez fait
part de votre scepticisme sur un
potentiel vaccin donc pour vous quelle
est l'option de recherche thérapeutique
à privilégier troisième question sur les
chiffres est ce que moi je suis d'accord
avec vous je trouve qu'il ya peu de
chiffres notamment des segmentations en
tout cas à partir des données brutes ce
que vous pensez qu'on les aura un jour
quatrième point vous m'avez déprimé sur
la recherche scientifique je pourrais
bien dire ce que j'aime beaucoup les
sciences et vous aviez écrit dans une
tribune en 2018 que vous regrettiez que
la science soit instrumentalisée au
service de l'idéologie et du commerce
alors comment on peut casser ça
je n'ai pas de solution miracle mais en
tout cas la description vous en avez
fait tout à l'heure je les trouvais un
peu angoissante
on va dire ça comme ça les dernières
questions sur la deuxième vague la
deuxième question vous avez déjà été
posée précédemment mais votre sentiment
c'est quoi vous savez le petit à petit
vous faisiez vous connaissez des objets
j'ai pas beaucoup de sentiments sur le
sur l'avenir je sais pas battu
donc je suis je crois que si j'ai un
talent dans la science et l'observation
jeu bon observateur je vois les choses
là où les gens ne voient pas mais je
suis pas un prophète un même si je suis
barbu je ne suis pas prophète du tout
donc je prophétise pas ce qui va se
passer le jour même sur quelque chose
qui est aussi bête que la grippe si vous
voulez on n'arrive pas à savoir si on va
voir une épidémie de grippe h1n1 ou de
hp n 3 et d'après des fois il n'avait
pas du tout des fois il ya de la bcc
d'une complexité l'évolution des
maladies infectieuses qui est très
grande
deuxièmement moi aussi je partage je
pense qu'il ya une véritable réflexion à
mener sur la recherche médicale sur son
orientation en particulier sur la
créativité
moi je trouve je suis j'imagine que ça
se voit je suis extrêmement heureux et
c'est donc ne vous inquiétez pas je sais
que pas de faire le vôtre ya aucune
chance sauf si on me fout de leurs mais
honnêtement encore je trouve à quelque
chose d'autre à faire j'adore écrire
c'est ce qui m'a été reproché on m'a
demandé comment j'arrive à écrire autant
parce que j'aime ça j'ai facilité pour
ça et donc je je je suis extrêmement
heureux parce que notre période et
merveilleuse mais je trouve que nos pays
mais mais l'ensemble de l'europe passe à
côté
alors que l'extrême orient on trouve on
est dans un pays dans le monde et dans
un monde dans lequel l'enjeu est un
enjeu des découvertes technologiques ce
que ce qu'on nous on appelle les au mix
qui ont commencé avec le génome ou déjà
la france avait pris un retard colossal
ont été les seuls à vouloir faire du
génome l'institut pasteur disait que le
génome c'est les bêtises que ça servait
à rien et donc nous on s'aimait à faire
les fous et les génomes on n'a pas
arrêté
on fait du des manants des séquences
permanente tout tous les jours tous les
jours on décide de faire le génome d'une
bactérie parce qu'il ya un effet
atypique essayer de comprendre pourquoi
et puis il ya eu les autres c'est
maintenant un léger les génomes 2 et
bien sûr c'est comme ça qu'on découvre
les virus de il ya les protéines 3 la
morphologie
4 les cultures dans tous les azimuts la
voyez pour répondre à la question que
s'est posée sur le vaccin rougeole on a
isolé sens où je voyais de rougeole on
est toutes en train de séquencer pour
regarder s'il ya de la variabilité qui
pourrait expliquer ça oui donc il ya des
choses qui sont qui sont donc je touche
je trouve que cette époque est un
miracle pour quelqu'un qui fait de la
biologie de la mire de la microbiologie
c'est merveilleux mais c'est pas là
dedans qu'on va et donc les derniers
arrivants vous savez c'est souvent comme
ça les derniers arrivants se sont mis
juste à faire ce qui arrivait sur sur
lequel il avait aucun retard et donc ils
ont commencé un suréquipement massif
c'est ce qu'on a vu en chine ce qu'on
voit encore est une technologie de
pointe extraordinaire qui va nous
fournir équipe qui a un développement
industriel hallucinant et donc c'est il
ya une révolution quotidiennes
actuellement de ça qui est
enthousiasmante qui est merveilleux
mais si je m'exprime de temps en temps
des temps amer c'est parce que c'est pas
moi je vous assure que nous on s'amuse
beaucoup beaucoup c'est très
excessivement intéressant l'on trouve
qu'on publie beaucoup mais j' ai encore
150 nouvelles espèces bactériennes que
l'on a décrit qu'on avait isolé chez
l'homme qu'on n'a pas le temps de
décrire tellement on a deux choses qui
sortent donc c'est merveilleux comme
temps
je regrette que cette cette mutation de
la science et de la recherche médicale
ne soit pas adoptée plus généralement
c'est ça que je regrette
et si vous voulez honnêtement pour vous
dire les essais thérapeutiques en
maladies infectieuses honnêtement ça
représente un intérêt qui est
extrêmement modestes on a besoin de très
très très très peu de choses équipe usée
il faut changer les modèles de pensée
c'est à dire que les modèles d'un je
crois en tout cas c'est ce que nous on
avait fait les modèles therapeutics et
c'est pas de faire des études
randomisées sous voulait savoir si un
médicament qui marche baptisée open sida
vous faites une charge virale et puis
vous le savez quoi regarder si virus
disparaisse il disparaît ces gens sont
plus malades au bout de quelques temps
ça aurait pu entraîner des baisses
considérables du coût du traitement de
l'hépatite c
s'ils ont décidé si vous voulez qu'après
trois tests ou la charge virale est
devenue négative en arrêter le
traitement
et puis on les surveille et puis si ça
recommence on les retraites voyez pas
jusque là on a imposé à une durée de
traitement qui était solidement imposé
qui était pas basée alors comme il ya
une variabilité considérable d'un
patient à l'autre
tout ça c'est pas de la médecine tout la
cdc les recettes salées et donc encore
une fois je voudrais bien je serais
heureux que jean se saisissent de cette
opportunité extraordinaire moi je dis
microbiologie c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il faut faire de moins en moins de
théorie c'est on est exactement si vous
voulez au xvième siècle en géographie
on est en train de découvrir le mans on
est en train de découvrir le microbiote
en train de découvrir que tout ça change
complètement
vous savez ce que c'est que le
médicament plus révolutionnaire qu'on
ait eue dans le 21e siècle pour les
maladies infectieuses en dehors du
traitement de pas de site c'est lui qui
avait commencé
vous savez ce que c'est la greffe est
calme si honteux c'est à dire qu'on
sauve des gens n'ont sauvé au moins 150
en leur faisant des greffes fécales donc
vous voyez que l'innovation ou s'est
trouvée l'innovation comment on va
remplacer cette innovation c'est quand
même ces espèces de bien qu elle a gaffé
quatre séries tout le monde qu'ils vont
le commercialiser
or déconstruit peut pas rapporter
d'argent pas le contrôler comment on va
faire avec ça après donc c'est un sujet
est terrible ça et pourtant ça c'est la
maladie émergente a plus qu'on a eu la
plus violente depuis 20 ans en france
cette huile de 1500 personnes par an en
france déclaré
je n'ai pas dit ça représente la moitié
de celles qui sont réelles donc il ya
des choses merveilleuses affaire
extraordinaire ça le microbiote
extraordinaire en ces temps on découvre
un bon c'est pas ce que ça va donner
est ce que c'est ça qui fait payer les
changements d'écosystèmes esquissons
médiée par les microbes
voyez ce que l'effet du froid est plutôt
sur les microbes des muqueuses nasales
qui les rendrait plus qui nous rendrait
plus vulnérable voyez donc on est dans
un monde découverte qui est génial qui
est extraordinaire donc je sais ça que
je regrette c'est que la course n'est
pas nous qui est l'absent tête je ne
croyais pas nourrir le fond quand on est
compétitif avec les chinois mais au prix
d'un équipement massif d'une stratégie
d' usage des outils actuels à ce qui est
en train de sortir maintenant maintenant
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps et c'est ce que je disais tout à
l'heure il est sorti un appareil apc qui
fait les pcr en 20 minutes vient de
corée on nous l'envoyons nous envoie
tout pour tester qui vient de corée qui
est grand comme ça elle vous faites le
test mettez le prélèvement de sang de ce
que voulait vingt minutes après et alors
qu actuellement il nous faut deux heures
ce sera un truc de cabinet donc vous
aurez besoin de réfléchir sur les
docteurs test est ce qu'on pourra faire
ça au cabinet oui ça va changer
complètement la prise en charge de
t'envoyer donc comment tout ça va
s'harmoniser avec la loi actuelle la
place des biologistes barbier si on
accepte de regarder ce qui est en train
de se passer dans le monde et la vitesse
à laquelle ça se développe
vous aurez des génomes humains demain on
fera le génome entier c'est pas bon pour
100 dollars je sais pas vous avez vu les
trucs de toi petit sou et demi ça coûte
100 dollars laissant aux états unis et
puis on vous prédit ce que vous allez
voir que mal face et ça notre monde
c'est un monde fou de vitesse de
technique c'est intéressant et si les
médicaments on utilise des vieux c'est
pas très grave
merci on a encore deux parlementaires
qui veulent poser des questions vous
m'avez pas répondu monsieur le
professeur sur l'immunité croisés alors
il ya on trouve on est en train de
travailler a su bien sûr quand on parle
de quelque chose bien sûr ça va pas on
essaie de ne pas se laisser dépasser
il ya une immunité croisés en
particulier avec le virus
enfin pour pour l'instant on n'a pas de
modèles expérimentaux mais on a pris des
gens qui avaient fait des infections par
des virus
corona on a beaucoup à plus de 2000 cas
et que chez qui on avait par hasard un
sérum pour regarder s'ils avaient des
anticorps contre avec ce que l'on voit
ce qui est significatif c'est celui qui
est plus près et qui s'appelle h qu'a
eue a plus souvent des anticorps contre
le coc vide que tous les autres ça on a
ça pour l'instant c'est ce qu'on a mais
à notre surprise pour des raisons que je
comprends mal en tout cas qui ait pas
l'hypothèse que j'avais au départ on n'a
pas plus ici on fait de la sérologie
en général on n'a pas plus d'anticorps
celle et les enfants que l'on en a chez
les sujets âgés avec une technique ultra
sensible à nouvelle star bloqué donc il
y a des réactions croisées maintenant
est-ce que les l'immunité des enfants et
est infra n'est pas détecté c'est bien
possible puisque le premier papier qui a
été publiée au montré de l'immunité
trouvé entre 40 et 70 % ce qui est
beaucoup plus que nous et ils regardent
et l'humidité cellulaire des lymphocytes
mémoire donc est ce qui a le plus de
mémoire dans notre corps salut
lymphocytes mémoire et e on peut trouver
mémoire chez eux contre pas sûr en
regardant simplement les anticorps même
avec des tests très subtil et donc c'est
possible mais il faudra arriver à ça or
dans les dents les virus en particulier
âge qui a eu l'idée d'une difficulté
effroyable à cultiver et donc c'est pas
facile de produire des choses avec ça
donc on travaille avec une équipe
d'immunologie ce qu'ils sont des stars
par yale qui sont les meilleurs au monde
mon point de vue action laurent
d'hydrogène et guizot kremer pour
essayer de regarder ce qui se passe dans
les infos site mémoire et de voir si les
anticorps convois sont des anticorps
croit enfin l'immunité qu'on voit passer
pas les anticorps et croisées entre les
autres coronas la bolivie servat merci
madame la présidente monsieur le
professeur out
la france est la france parce que les
archipélagique parce que le soleil ne se
couche jamais sur les trois océans grâce
à ses territoires ultramarins sur les
trois océans
il se trouve que le virus nous a touchés
en outre-mer de façon variée très peu
pour beaucoup le territoire
d'ailleurs dix des onze territoires
ultramarins sont finalement tropicaux
avec des températures élevées toute
l'année avec un taux d'humidité
important sauf sa pierre et miquelon
donc j'aimerais savoir deux choses la
première c'est que est-ce que vous
identifier une raison on est liée entre
la propagation et l'intensité du virus
et les températures et les taux
d'humidité et deuxième question nous
avons deux territoires aujourd'hui
qu'ils sont plus sévèrement touchés que
d'autres c'est mayotte et la guyane
est-ce que vous avez des explications à
ce taux de contamination plus élevé
qu'ailleurs
non la glâne c'est tout là c'est non
c'est non mais en l'épidémie c'est
jusqu'à yen n'en où c'est toute la
lumière c'est toute la guyane est
compris
du côté de la frontière où est lié avec
le brésil
non honnêtement le jeu
je ne sais pas pour une maladie qui a
été beaucoup beaucoup plus étudiée comme
le la grippe on arrive mal à comprendre
quels sont les facteurs dans la zone
parce qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup moins
de travaux dans la zone intertropicale
lui beaucoup moins de travaux que ce
qu'il ya eu dans la zone tempérée et
donc déjà dans la zone tampon on
comprend pas réellement la saisonnalité
je sais pas le rôle que joue le dans la
grippe ce que je peux dire c'est que
c'est vrai que c'est dans la saison des
plus qu'un le plus c'est donc c'est
pendant le léthé tropicale qu' il ya le
plus de cas de grippe mais il y en a
toute l'année
la différence de ce qui passe dans les
pays tempérés donc ce qui va se passer
c'est une vraie question c'est très
important on hâte de travailler avec
beaucoup de deux pays du sud
c'est une question qui va se poser c'est
comment ça va se passer là dans les mois
qui viennent est-ce qu'il va y avoir un
continuum
est-ce que ça va continuer parce que
bien entendu si c'est le cas ça veut
dire que ça peut être une source doré
infestation dans un an et redéclencher
un épisode épidémique donc c'est une
vraie question très importante de
surveiller ce qui se passe ailleurs
bien sûr on l'a vu des virus veillée
voyage beaucoup c'est une vraie question
je ne sais pas y répondre parce qu'enfin
je ne sais pas les conditions qui
détermine que maladies épidémiques à un
instant donné et dans un endroit donné
sont pas connues en général oui bien que
même en france on n'arrive pas à savoir
pourquoi n'y en a pas dans l'ouest et on
a eu tellement dans l'est
même si on retrouve un événement
déclenchant donc je réellement je suis
ignorant mais je crois que tout le monde
l'est donc je sais pas il faut observer
parce que si on observe on peut toujours
imaginer que ce qui est faux mais ce qui
est moins faut que de d'inventer
complètement
on peut imaginer que le
le futur semble en partie au passé donc
si on arrive à observer ce qui se passe
maintenant on n'y comprendra donc on y
verra plus clair mais pour l'instant à
ce stade là il faut parier anglais
ailleurs il faut tester tout ce qu'on
peut il faut essayer de collecter les
choses voir quelle est la cinétique de
la courbe en faisant des tests les tests
lte est une aiguille adsav au pays c'est
un beau pays mais je viens de la
guadeloupe
or dans mon pays c'est un très beau pays
philippe berta merci madame la
présidente professeur deux petits points
là la lr l'accueillir tpr donc que vous
mentionnez donc sur le génome viral
c'est quoi aujourd'hui encore le taux de
faux négatifs ou de faux positifs
question qui peut se poser sur la
cuirasse idée des tests que vous
pratiquez deuxième point pour nous donc
c'est que le rock'n'roll a mentionné
aussi c'est une vieille histoire
on voit les premières publications
effectivement au début des années 2000
avec des effets de sur l'entrée du virus
dans les cellules liées à des problèmes
de péage sur les endosomes enfin non pas
rentrer dans ces détails là mais c'est
comparer à d'autres molécules et
finalement même le chlorure d'ammonium a
grosso modo le même effet que la
chloroquine sur ses cultures de cellules
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
pourquoi on va pas plus loin à ce moment
là en terme de recherche
puisqu'on était dans l'épisode sera ce
j'imagine dernier point vous avez
effectivement obtenu grâce au grand
emprunt la les plus beaux si la chute de
ce pays
l'une des rolls roce de l'infectiologie
mondiale
la question que je me pose quand même et
je sais je suis pas la seule à me poser
mais pourquoi pourquoi n'avez vous pas
fait des essais cliniques digne de ce
nom dès le départ qui aurait pu
définitivement répondre oui ou non
l'hydro xi chloroquine a un effet
pourquoi vous êtes vous cantonner à des
publications que vous êtes je connais
tous vos travaux sur les risques et si
je connais vos travaux sur les maxi
virus etc
donc je connais votre science bien
établie vous saviez très bien qu'en
publiant ces pseudos aux essais
thérapeutiques
si le pseudo essais cliniques en fait il
n'était absolument pas recevables par
qui que ce soit parce que quand on se
retrouve sur une publication à la fin
avec six patients on sait très bien que
c'est pas un essai clinique
alors pourquoi vous ne l'avez pas fait
c'étaient ces cliniques c'est nous
titille
tous dans dans notre communauté dès le
départ c'est un peu facile de remettre
en cause le système des essais
thérapeutiques
enfin c'est ce qui se pratique et qui va
se continuer à part ceux pratiqués
travers ce rassemblement dans
l'affection logique y compris non je
suis pas d'accord avec ça d'une part ce
que nous avons fait c'est ce que ce que
ce que ce qui se fait de plus simplement
c'est à dire quand on fait un essai
thérapeutique si vous voulez quand les
choses deviennent significatives on n'a
cessé de l'éthique basale et l'éthique a
rien à voir avec la méthodologie ces
deux choses distinctes les types basale
c'est que quand on a la preuve que
quelque chose marche et on doit le faire
à mi-chemin canton la preuve que quelque
chose marche on arrête le sait et donc
je suis désolé que vous n'aimez pas mais
bon et c'est moi je les aime beaucoup et
je trouve qu'il a toutes les bases d'un
essai de la seule manière de faire des
essais et de faire des essais
comparatifs et d'avoir une différence
significative et contrairement à ce que
vous dites c'est ça alors là je m'excuse
mais alors c'est une erreur radical - ya
de gens quand c'est significatif et plus
c'est significatif
quand vous avez dix mille pertes vous
êtes obligés d'avoir dix mille personnes
dans un essai pour montech une
significativité c'est qu'il n'y a aucune
différence parce que je vais vous dire
il ya quinze pour cent des gens qui ne
prennent même pas les médicaments qu'on
l'a prescrit donc quand vous cherchez
des différences de 20%
vous n'êtes plus dans la médecine vous
êtes dans du fantasme méthodologique
donc tout essai qui comporte plus de
mille personnes est un essai qui cherche
à démontrer les choses qui n'existent
pas et je suis désolé c'est une base de
la statistique et je vous assure que je
suis un très bon méthodologistes donc
c'est du fantasme qu'on voit qu'on
répète à tour de bras qui est véhiculée
par des gens qui sont des méthodologies
ce qu'ils ne comprennent rien à la
science la méthodologie n'est pas de la
science c'est un outil de la science ça
n'a rien à voir donc il faut pas me dire
que mes essais ne sont pas parce que
vous avez dit avant et c'est vrai je
suis un grand scientifique je sais ce
qui est un essai et je peux vous dire il
ya une dizaine d traitement que j'ai
inventés qui sont dans tous les livres
de référence médicaux et celui là il
sera aussi je vous le dis nous verrons
mais je peux vous dire et il faut
arrêter il faut les regarder les livres
médicaux il faut regarder en maladies
infectieuses combien il ya des sait
combien il y adeux thérapeutique qui
sont utilisés actuellement qui ont été
basées sur des essais randomisés vous
verrez il y en a pas beaucoup et le peu
qui ya été en particulier pour le sida
totalement inutile parce qu'il suffisait
de faire des charges virales
donc c'est pas vrai c'est de l'intox
c'est pas vrai ça disparaîtra comme
c'est apparu
une vingtaine d'années c'est de l'intox
je vous suggère d'ailleurs plutôt que
vous avez qu à le dire parce que c'est
intelligent sur la version de wikipedia
en anglais vous avez qu à lire vous
verrez qu'il ya la moitié qui dit voilà
il faut faire des essais randomisés
l'autre moitié qui dit voilà pourquoi il
faut pas en faire et vous verrez que je
suis pas isolé dans ce monde et que
globalement tous les gens font critiquer
ça je le redis d'ailleurs et il faut le
lire et il faut écouter ce que je dis
tous les gens qui ont critiqué sa non
publié que des essais comparatifs non
randomisé il n'y a pas un essai français
randomisés comparatif il n'y a pas même
année ces français qui est le degré de
2,2 d'isolement des stratégies
thérapeutiques comme l'autre 0 c'est que
des gens qui dans les hôpitaux ont
traité un peu comme ils voulaient à la
fin on dit regardez comment on compare
donc il faut pas mettre les choses à
l'envers
j'étais avant un grand scientifique et
je suis resté un grand scientifique
après avoir publié bien s'il n'y a plus
d'autres questions je vais vous
remercier infiniment confesseur out pour
la clarté de vos réponses et puis la
longueur de cette audition mais un grand
merci monsieur le rapporteur
oui je m'associe madame la présidente à
vos remerciements je crois que cette
audition a été très dense très riche
avec avec beaucoup d'éléments
nous avons mesuré je crois à la fois vos
convictions mais on n'est pas dans un
sujet de conviction aux compétences
surtout votre expérience
je relève aussi avec gravité s'est
naturellement pour notre commission un
sujet qui va déboucher sur sur des
suites sur des auditions au moins dans
un premier temps que vous avez porté des
graviers des accusations extrêmement
graves sur des
des instances qui sont aujourd'hui
installés et qui ont ouvert la question
des conflits d'intérêts nous serons
amené naturellement je le serai a
exploré cette voie que que vous nous
avez indiqué qu'ils nous connaissions
naturellement mais vous l'avez fait
devant devant cette commission et
naturellement elle doit nous conduire à
en tirer toutes les conséquences en tout
cas merci pour pour les éléments que
vous nous avez apporté pour l'éclairage
qui a été le vôtre est aussi je veux le
dire également pour pour l'action
sanitaire que vous avez conduite pour
pour notre pays je vous remercie
voilà vous venez d'entendre le
professeur didier rahout il est revenu
sur la stratégie qu'il a choisi de mener
contre l'épidémie de coronavirus cette
audition comme toutes celles de la
commission denquête est à retrouver sur
notre site
lcp point fr